Three separate hospital oncology departments have now recommended radiation and chemotherapy as a treatment
combination that they would employ to fight my head and neck cancer, which has been classified as stage two.
Though the radiologist considers it stage three due to the tumor sizes and the number of lymph nodes. It's in two or more beats tomorrow, but it's no key. Like they
weekly
weekday radiation, high dose, transplant weekly for seven weeks. If I do of another course of healing for these tumors, I would consider following that course, but I don't
remember you are doing a lot of things and
doing the things that you're doing if the cancer is continuing to grow, you know, if you're doing everything you possibly can and the tumors continue to grow.
Then using, you know, a harsher course of care, maybe the right thing doesn't mean you have to do, you know, everything that they're telling you to do, meeting the entire course of seven weeks. Maybe you're only going to do two, three rounds of it and you feel like it's
trinketed doing well and you, you know, feel like God is leading you to step back from that, then that's your choice. So you don't have to do the full course that they're saying, and I would ask them to see, you know, is it progressing. That's the biggest thing
to keep these small, is there any other alternative course you'd recommend the tumors are affecting my swallowed speech and could affect my airway at some point.
We have other people I don't think they're on tonight's call that have this same type of cancer that have had issues and a fear of that it's going to affect their airway
and some have chosen to do some radiation and some people and it helped and they're done with that and they did well through it. So don't be afraid to do that.
Just don't just make the decision based upon wisdom and based upon prayer.
And when I say wisdom, I mean, okay, that's just be wise about it. If it's progressing with everything you're doing that maybe it is wise to at least consider prayerfully to do some of the quote unquote bigger guns that, you know, nobody wants to do but using that can knock it down with everything that you're doing.
If you must go this course or their things that you that I might request or negotiate to make it less harmful.
Not really for them. There's not going to be anything that they're going to be able to do to make it less harmful
But you should have a conversation with me. We should talk about if there is anything that we want to do from a nutritional standpoint.
We need like we do on our blog. You can see we do have if you search this for a chemo protocol. We have a chemo protocol on there. And I think it's on the member site as well that it typically recommends that you, you know, go off of
all your antioxidants for a period of time, 48 hours after the administration of chemo. Then you could go back on them and that you do a 24 hour fast prior to the administration of chemo. That, of course, is me as means that if you're doing an IV chemo therapy. So if you're doing chemo therapy at 9 o'clock Monday morning, you start fasting at 9 o'clock Sunday morning before chemo.
And then you would go off of any antioxidant nutrition. And we could help you identify what that is in your protocol. And you'd go off of that for 48 hours. So you wouldn't go back on that until Wednesday sometime afternoon.